strategically can we all agree that that
story was
held till the week prior to the election
because that's the bond that we're gonna
drop to flip the voting at the last
minute we all know
that would have been intentional it's
not like they just got the story last
minute if i'm a skeptic i'm assuming new
york post had that story for a while
and they were timing on when to drop it
that's my skepticism i may be wrong
so
and in politics stories matter on
timing matters on when they drop it so
he
essentially affected the election so
dorsey has essentially affected the
election the fact that he's saying it
now
i think he's more doing this to say
don't come bothering me for 2024.
i i don't disagree with you so i will i
will say that i don't necessarily agree
that the washington
uh the wall street journal washington
times whoever broke the story i'm not
saying that they dropped the story when
they dropped it specifically to change
the direction of the election they
dropped it at a very intentional time
most likely to get maximum readers
maximum views of their advertisement
maximum you know press coverage and
secondary like viral coverage not to
sway an election but what i will also
say is that there is only one person or
not one person there's one entity that
has the responsibility for the way the
elections turned out and that's the
american people if you stood in line and
you voted you own the vote that you cast
that day
zuckerberg did not change the course of
the election
did he have a tool that could have been
used to sway it sure but ultimately
somebody went and stood in line cast a
vote and that's the person who owns the
responsibility for the outcome right now
that's the person who owns the
responsibility for every single outcome
that's why you have to vote that's why
you have the right to vote we just have
to understand especially if you look at
2020 2020 was a freakish year a hard
time processing that i have a very hard
time processing that so you're telling
me
the person who voted has the ultimate
responsibility for the results for the
vote they cast for the vote they cast i
understand but
the journalists have a responsibility
for digging up and getting the
information
to the people so they can read it before
voting to be as educated as possible
journalists and these virtual
governments such as facebook twitter
youtube have to permit that information
to be released to the public so they can
make the most educated vote which they
prevent it from happening so you can't i
have a hard time saying in this case
that it's the voters responsibility on
the way they voted no they did not have
access to the entire information this
article says 79 say truthful coverage of
hunter biden's laptop would have changed
the 2020 election
and the numbers they gave us majority in
both parties 89 of republicans which is
fine that makes i'm surprised it's not
99 republicans but 89 of republicans
61
of democrats
said they believe the laptop is real
along with 74
of independence so if the difference
between it coming out a week versus a
week after that that's a very big
difference right let me show you a quick
spy tool right so um what's what's our
i'm sorry title tyler do me a favor go
to this article
and then look up the specific survey i
did this after i saw this article i want
to show you exactly how special jersey i
looked at it yeah i saw that yeah the
first thing i did this is what new york
post did you see the population that
they test one thousand uh uh 226 1 226
you know what a statistical relevant
population is what's that 3 000
okay so this is not a statistical not a
statistically relevant representation of
a survey result they could essentially
have called 1022
old republicans in a single district to
ask them this question and get this
result surveys are no to polls are no i
trust two polls i trust two polls is
this one of them no that's not one of
them so this is this is what i'm saying
about what i tell you yesterday by the
way what i said to you yesterday when i
said look up the poll who's the buyer
uh i said i tell you which two polls
i'll pay attention to your uh uh gallop
i'll pay attention to them i'm not going
past
the direct everything else i'll like
temple
yep no i totally get it i fully get it
so these guys when i looked at this
that's when i was like well they can
shape their pace forget about these guys
just just the four of us talking right
now and whoever else that's watching
this right you mean to tell me the story
not being released didn't impact the
story did so here's i want to make sure
that we're aligning responsibility in
the right place please zuckerberg does
not zuckerberg runs a business he does
not run a second government a federal a
commercial government a shadow
government he runs a business
the journalists have a journalistic
responsibility to report the facts amen
1 000 true journalism
is dying journalism some people say is
fully dead and the journalists who write
for most of these mainstream news
sources hate the way that the editors
handle their journalistic
responsibilities because the editor does
not have a journalistic responsibility
like the journalist does
so they're forced to produce at a
certain speed before they can do what's
needed to meet journalistic requirements
and then information is controlled by a
business that wants to spend its time
being you know protective of its own
long-term business interests i'm sure
you get that
and then what's left is the human being
the person the american on the other
side is scrolling through facebook only
reading what they see
and we have given that person that
american has got the permission now to
think that it's okay to get your news
from facebook it's not okay to get your
news from facebook it's not okay to get
your news from just one source of
anything but but
what do you mean it's not okay to get
your news from facebook though facebook
isn't a platform where i get my news
from because they write it facebook is
where stories go viral correct twitter
is where stories go viral correct for
you to prevent a very damaging story
to not go viral for the public to know
before they vote knowing this is a very
corrupt
situation here
you're uh essentially manipulating the
election and then the world paid a price
for it because if the election was a
possibly in a different way say somebody
else becomes president
russia probably doesn't attack ukraine
lives could have been saved there we
probably don't lose 83 billion dollars
of equipment in afghanistan because that
would have been handled in a different
way
and you know economy would probably be
in a slightly different place inflation
would be in a different place many
things would be in a different place
if it wasn't for the and the american
people today are paying a price for it
yesterday poll came out i don't know if
you saw the poll or not on who they're
saying the leading candidate is
for presidency did you see that or not
it was a story by fox okay so story came
out what page is that on page seven so
you've seen this i'll read it to you
so page seven this is yesterday
uh uh uh uh is it paid seven
do you know which one i'm looking at uh
tyler or yeah bottom of six are you
talking about bernie sanders no it's not
that one it's another one where it says
bernie sanders is the leading candidate
yeah leading the polls
uh yeah it's page six is it page six
yeah okay so if i go it's a hill story
high school so sanders
sanders has highest favorability among
possible 2024 contender poll this is a
hill story this is not a fox story or
cnn sanders clocked in with the highest
favorability rating amongst the list of
23 potential 2024 candidate con
presidential contenders according to a
new usa today poll
46 of the respondents say they had at
least a somewhat favorable view towards
sanders while 41 said they had an
unfavorable opinion president biden had
the second highest at rating of 43
percent
although his unfavorability was notably
higher than sanders at 52
and then you know trump clocked in with
the same rating as biden so again polls
usa today we know which side they're
going to lean of course they're going to
want a sanders you know because it's
going to be sample size yeah they're
going to want to be able to use that
part as well but at the same time i
think when you're saying facebook
twitter these guys don't have a
responsibility i think they have a
responsibility of allowing the message
to be released
the populace what the populace you and i
the citizens the voters have a
responsibility for
is not to jump to conclusions to do our
own due diligence before voting but that
the responsibility is for them so
releasing of the information is on
facebook
they got to release that part okay the
information is out there regardless of
whether it's on facebook i could just
get it from a different news source i
know bro but i can post the same video
clip on instagram on facebook on twitter
on youtube on tick tock and all of a
sudden one of them like for example tick
tock i'll tell you perfect situation if
you go back look at my tic tac account
i was posting videos and i was getting
100 views 600 000 views 100 000 views
800 000 5 million views 2.1 million is
1.8 million views i post two clips about
china
find the clip after it's been 50 videos
since that clip find the clip after that
if any one of them have ever done 10 000
views
i'm like okay content is content one of
the clips posted by somebody else got
six million views of the same thing i
said on a smaller platform posted it but
i put it on mine it got 11 000 views so
virality is about the gods of viral to
allow an article to go viral
today when an article is going viral
social media they know when the
trigger's back in uh oh look at this
this thing's going viral what is it okay
let it go oh this thing's going right oh
yeah let it go oh this thing's going
wrong shut it down shut it down shut it
down shut it down shut it
goes like this i've seen videos on on
november 22nd
five years ago i did an interview with
jim jenkins and jim jenkins was one of
the four guys that held john f kennedy's
brain he was in the autopsy room he
stayed quiet for 50 years christian man
quiet man never wanted to talk to
anybody who was afraid because they told
him if you say anything we're going to
take the navy money away from you so
this guy doesn't want to talk finally he
says i want to talk about it but he
comes in if you ever see the interview
it was so nervous
we put it out on november 22nd which is
the assassination day the video goes
like this boom
boom
boom
then suddenly it went like this right
that doesn't happen what platform
youtube that doesn't happen it went like
this
and then it stayed like this okay
so what does that mean wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute hold this
thing back
a person on the back and when i look at
my creative studios i can see i've never
in the history of my 1800 videos i've
ever seen a video do that
why is this happening sometimes these
types of things happen because these
platforms have the ability to prevent
these types of toxins to become
converted so that's my only concern with
facebook and i think i want to be able
to be an optimist and i think
what zuck is trying to say is guys next
time we're on fbi we're telling the
story and we're not getting in the way i
think that's what he's saying now
whether he'll follow through with that
or not we have no idea so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]